the following memorandum is classified
and falls under your TS 7 6e
non-disclosure agreement any deviation
from this will result in maximum
prosecution
fifty-eight the Soviet Union launched
the Verona one satellite to secure their
lead in the space race the Verona
entered stable orbit around Earth moon
Lagrange point to and began transmitting
deep-space telemetry back to earth but
after communication ceased a manned
mission was set to investigate when the
repair team found no external issues
Soviet leadership what did the
cosmonauts to breach the satellite in
the moments that followed the cosmonauts
encountered something unprecedented a
non terrestrial life-form all members of
the mission were lost the footage was
labeled a state secret and buried after
two years of silence
the Soviets contacted the US and pleaded
for help with containing the threat
Kennedy agreed
in 1963 the US Soviet collaboration
resulted in the clicker program a
permanent installation to containment on
terrestrials but the historic
partnership was short-lived
following a failed assassination attempt
an emboldened Kennedy returned to office
and seized control of the joint program
and in the two decades that followed the
u.s. evolved the station into a fully
functional R&D facility American team
studied the nonterrestrials now labeled
- but were unable to harness their
enigmatic abilities into military or
commercial applications after an
unfortunate containment failure led to
the death of an entire research team the
u.s. shuttered the project in 1998 the
station was abandoned the Transtar
corporation secured the derelict station
and transformed it into Talos 1 a
cutting-edge Innovation Center in just
five short years the team aboard Talos 1
has achieved a greater understanding of
the Typhon organisms than three decades
of government research and soon
innovations from our psychotronics
division will redefine what it means to
be human
you